foreign
here we go again it's facts or your
friends let's do it
oh geez all right today we are talking
about how to find a therapist
how to find a therapist we've talked
about this on the show before and it
continues to be one of the most
um common questions we get how do I find
a counselor how to find a therapist how
to find a social worker what's the
difference all that kind of stuff okay
so we're going to talk about how to find
the right therapist I'm going to give
you a couple of bullet points here that
you can follow
um pull out a pen and a paper write this
stuff down
um so here we go number one I want to
Define what they are and what they are
not okay so when you think of mental
health professional
you can start with your local doctor and
your doctor your regular doctor your
primary care physician is going to get a
couple of classes on Mental Health stuff
on psychiatric stuff
um they're not gonna usually get
questions
classes on how to deal with trauma in
fact almost never on how to sit with
somebody over the long a long period of
time
um I will tell you the first time I went
to go get help I went and met with a
medical doctor but he was a buddy so I
had a relationship with him and remember
the word relationship because that's
going to be really important
a psychiatrist is a medical doctor okay
that's a medical doctor who goes to med
school and then goes on to specialize in
psychiatric care mental health issues
I'm sad to say that most Psychiatry
nowadays is entirely medicine based it's
it's entirely biological
very few classes if any on therapy on
sitting with somebody it's all moved to
manage care get you in hear your your X
number of symptoms give you a diagnosis
ic10 codes or out of the DSM and then
get you on get your meds and get you out
of here okay
um Psychiatry I think can be used great
as an adjunct to counseling care and
most of the research suggests that you
need to have that medicine works in
conjunction with
um counseling some sort of talk therapy
or some sort of Action Therapy but
and so where some people start okay some
people start there
a psychologist a psychologist
is the next rung if you only hierarchy
so if you look at mental health
professionals there's a hierarchy there
whether we want there to be one or not
and it's psychiatrists which are medical
doctors and then there's a psychologist
psychologists go to get a graduate
degree you gotta have a PhD or a psyd to
to be called a clinical psychologist and
they are trained usually from research
more research based they've got to do
research they have to do studies they're
going to be more clinical in their
approach
um more typologies this and again I'm
speaking broadly and generally beneath
that depending on which state you are in
it might be counselor it might be a
marriage and family therapist it might
be a social worker clinical licensed
clinical social worker and there's
social workers that are licensed to sit
with people they can do diagnosis they
can refer you out to psychiatrist and
then there's social workers that are to
help you navigate complex systems like a
medical system or the legal system or
whatever
so I'm talking about licensed clinical
social workers
at the end of the day
the research tells me that the most
important thing is not the modality not
the degree
of a licensed mental health professional
it's the Rapport between
the patient the client and the mental
health professional
how you feel interacting with this
person now I was thinking about this
when I was writing these notes out for
this
two of the most amazing therapists that
I refer to a lot
whose wisdom guides a lot of what I do
or Esther perel and Terry reel Terence
real
neither of them have phds neither of
them are Dr perel or Dr
um real
and they're amazing
my therapist the person I go to I know
they don't have a PhD I know they're not
a doctor so and so and I don't know what
their clinical licensure is in I
actually don't know
I know they're one of the most respected
and extraordinary counselors in the
United States and I was really fortunate
that she would take me on
um but I don't even know what her
clinical licensure is That's how little
I care about that kind of crap also
Gabor mate who you hear me talk about a
lot he's a medical doctor not a
psychiatrist but a medical doctor so all
that to say is and I have two phds and
I'm seeing somebody who's not a PhD all
that I want you to me say I don't care
it's about when you meet with this
person do you click
and here's how I know if I if I click
can I or will I tell this person the
truth
most of us have an innate sense that
this person in front of us is not safe
or they are safe doesn't mean it's not
going to be uncomfortable it's not going
to be weird
but can I tell them the truth
will I tell them the truth
if you sit down in front of somebody and
your guard immutably goes up you are not
you're wasting your time you're wasting
their time you're wasting your money
because if you're not going to tell the
truth and they can't help you it's like
going to the doctor and not telling them
that your foot is really really hurting
and instead tell them you got a headache
it's not gonna help they're never gonna
get you the x-rays that you need to get
your your care okay so the most
important thing is the relationship with
your therapist can you tell the truth if
you need meds if you think you need meds
you can start anywhere with any of these
folks and they will let you know
we've tried some things for a few weeks
I think it's best to refer you out to
your doctor or to a psychiatrist and
they will have lists of people they can
refer you out to okay so oh and one one
more quick side note here
life coaches
um Here's my thought on life coaches I
actually have one of those too and I
know that that's a lot I've got a life
coach and having a therapist
I don't go to my life coach the person I
sit with his name is Justin McRoberts
he's amazing
I don't go to him with
childhood traumas I don't go to him with
really deep structural marriage issues
when my wife and I are struggling I
don't go to him with like parenting
challenges I go to him when I have a
specific problem that I need to solve
that I'm struggling with like my
calendar like feeling sensitive all the
time when people give me feedback at
work like when I've got four or five
people at work all tell me the same
thing but I think I'm right he provides
a mirror for me and is able to say
things more directly often than a
counselor will that's what a coach is
coaches give you advice not always but
more so than a therapist will
um
I am technically not licensed I
intentionally did not get licensed in
the state of Tennessee
um because I didn't want to spend my
whole career fighting grenades that
people were throwing for licensure so
life coaches can get certified in their
particular thing but not all of them
have licenses and stuff it's great I
take specific and issues like boundaries
work challenges etc for life coaching so
if you're working through like a
particular issue call life coach man
it's easier to get in sometimes they can
be less expensive sometimes depending on
who you call sometimes they can be
extraordinarily expensive
um but I don't have a problem at all in
fact I employ one and if you want to
check out Justin McRoberts he's the guy
that I work with and he's amazing he's
out of California and we do it virtually
and it's awesome
um all right so how to find the right
therapist all right number one I hate
that I have to start here but this is
the world we're in right now
I hate that I have to start here
figure out your finances
um usually it's gonna be between 75
bucks and 250 bucks an hour sometimes a
little bit less if they're on a sliding
scale sometimes more sliding scale
simply means you're a teacher you make
forty two thousand dollars a year and
they are going to slide their rates down
and make you you will pay less than
somebody who makes a hundred thousand
dollars a year might have to pay full
full Freight great I'm a hundred percent
on board with sliding scale stuff okay
psychiatrists can be considerably more
expensive for 500 bucks an hour
sometimes testing is thousands of
dollars
um it just depends on what you need if
you've got cash pay many many many many
therapists have moved to cash pay
usually because their books are full
they don't have to deal with insurance
they can just say hey I cost 150 bucks
an hour people write them a check and
they'll move on
if you can afford to do that great
that's where I would start
um one side note you can pay with cash
and you can say like I do with my
counselors
I do not want any diagnosis in any
records
so they don't and I'm paying with cash
if you have insurance if you are going
through your insurance often insurance
will require a diagnosis to reimburse
the therapist so they have to put
something down
um so if you got cash pay start there if
you need to run it through your
insurance great my wife has done that no
big deal at all no big deal at all
um run it through your insurance and you
can often find a list of practitioners
in your area okay now finding
practitioners is hard
there is a shortage Nationwide it just
is
that's not an excuse to give up if you
need to talk to somebody okay it's not
an excuse
you need to know how much things will
cost before you go and by the way no
therapist should be upselling you things
or giving you packages on things or that
should never happen okay that should
never ever happen
and a therapist's job
should be to work themselves out of a
job with you their job is not to counsel
you for eternity
their job is to help you in the healing
process to walk alongside you okay if
you are struggling to find somebody a
group and I know they sponsor the show
so there you go but better help has been
extraordinary
um to folks who were just who were
peripheral to the Nashville shooting
that's who I referred them to got him a
code for better help okay so I have full
trust there I refer people that I care
about and love to better help no problem
at all and their promise is they will
see you within 24-48 hours okay dealing
with deep trauma online therapy or
talking on the phone therapy might not
be the best long term but man it's a
great place to get you going okay so
number two
after you've dealt with the finances
what you can afford how you can work
that thing
have an idea as to what you want to talk
about
have some sort of Direction okay I'm
ready to stop being so angry I want to
be a more present mom I want to be a
better dad than my dad I don't even know
where to start I just keep crying all
the time
everyone around me is telling me that
I'm depressed I keep asking if I'm
depressed I don't think I am
but it's time for me to talk to somebody
get a different a third party who's
who's neutral on this deal okay
more than likely you're going to be
wrong and what you think is going on
I can't tell you the number of times
I've gone in and been like hey I need to
talk about X and within an hour we are
not talking about X we are talking about
why X is simply a symptom of why and a b
and c and d and e and f and g right but
have some sort of direction if you plop
down on the couch and you look at the
therapist and say fix me it's not going
to work good therapists can work with
that because they're good but man it
really helps to sit down and say I'm
ready to stop hurting
I am in the last stages of my life and I
want to have as much joy as possible I
just lost somebody that that means that
was my heartbeat and I can't breathe can
you help me with the grief and and so
have some sort of Direction there okay
um and I want to reiterate this you got
to tell the truth
you gotta tell the truth they teach us
in counseling 101 classes your clients
will lie to you your clients will lie to
you don't lie if you're gonna go and
you're gonna pay the money tell the
truth I slept with this many people I
hooked up with my bosses
um uh secretary and it's going to blow
my marriage up I hit my kid go tell the
truth okay
um all right number uh three where
should you look okay
number one check the internet in your
local area that's the easiest way okay
and there are waiting lists all over the
country get on them get on the waiting
list
just like your Barber who books four
months out or three months or whatever
get on the waiting list you never know
when you're gonna get a call okay so
number one get on a waiting list if four
or five or six people are like dude you
gotta go see Jenna you gotta go see
Jenna you got to go see Jenna and you
call Jenna and says hey I might take any
clients now but I got a waiting list get
on it go ahead and get on it why not
right why not but don't stop there
um after you've checked your local uh
internet uh if you check the local the
internet in your local area
ask friends families or co-workers
listen you are worth being well so
unless you're an abusive situation or
somebody that's going to take advantage
of you for for finding out that you're
going to a counselor
I let folks know
I see somebody and I got a coach my wife
sees somebody we will see somebody
together
ah it's fine it's great it's healthy
it's good most of the people I know
um who do hard things and have have hard
things in their past need to go do the
work they need to do the work okay let
people know more often than not somebody
will be like hey you should go see my
person they're great okay
also if you live in a community with a
with a local University call and find
out in West Texas where I just was
um the local University there was a
counseling program an Addiction
Counseling program a marriage and family
therapy program a psychology program the
medical school has a counseling program
all of them have things called clinics
the clinics are where graduate students
see clients for free or for very very
reduced rates and before you go I'm not
seeing no student I was a student
I was a student that's where I saw
clients
and so my colleagues were great it's a
great place to go and if you go see a a
graduate student
you're getting the benefit of not only
the graduate student but often one or
two professors
so people with extensive experience and
so sometimes you get a benefit of two or
three therapists for the price of a
quarter of one right it can be an
amazing resource so if you live in a
local community check out the Clinics of
the mental health programs at the local
University it's a great
um way to get in and see somebody
um and you can also provide feedback
it's just awesome
um there's also local family counseling
services that are designed for folks who
have no money or very very little money
it's where I did my one of my
internships my practicums and I loved it
I loved it
um there's a great place to meet folks
all over the the Spectrum who are
struggling with things and also people
who had plenty of money that I got to
help so check out local family
counseling services or counseling
resources in your area as well and then
also there's church services
I do have a bias
I do have a bias and so it's just this
is just me
um there are good well-meaning uh
ministers that are not trained
that will often talk to folks
and unfortunately I've I've had a career
of people coming to me and being like
hey man I went and saw my pastor and
they said X and Y and Z and I just go oh
my gosh I cannot believe they said that
so I do have a bias against sprinting
out that way
I implore you if you're a pastor or a
minister you have to know when you're
over your head
you have to not look at people and say
well if you just prayed harder
or Jesus tells you don't be anxious so
uh
that's not helpful and in fact that
hurts people don't be that Pastor don't
be that Minister there's tons of
pastoral counselor training that you can
go get that will make you incredibly
effective and I hope that everyone who
has the
um the courage
to sit with somebody who's hurting we'll
go through the proper training there
okay so
that's basically oh here's the other one
call better help man call online service
they will get you in within 24-48 hours
if you're just stuck
again it's not often you're not going to
do this forever and ever and ever amen
but man it can be a great resource
when you finally get the courage up to
say okay I'm going I'm going last thing
I want to pass along here
go
uh three times three to four times
before you decide to switch a therapist
okay
the first time should be a nervous vomit
session
you get it all out this happened and
this happened and this happened and
there's a thing that you're like I don't
want to say I don't say it and you say
it or you don't say it
that's the first session the second one
is awkward it's the second date you're
going back
you feel a little bit better because you
finally spoke out loud some of this crap
that you've been carrying around you
finally said my husband sucks I don't
know what to do I'm sick of my kids not
liking me
that's just that's that's the that's the
let's look forward to the book you
didn't start the book yet the work comes
so what are we gonna do now
okay second session is usually context
tell me how you grew up tell me about
your past tell me how long you've been
married how did you meet why all that
kind of digging into stuff it's
uncomfortable it doesn't feel like
you're getting anywhere you're building
relationship with the council you're
practicing saying your needs out loud
you're practicing telling the truth out
loud
session three is when things get hard
usually
that's when you start getting more
homework assignments you may get like a
timeline assignment or something like
that like put in the timeline here or I
want you to write down your listing you
might get some of that stuff in the
first couple sessions session three
session four is when you start doing the
work
we're going to learn some breathing
exercises because we got to talk about
some hard stuff
we are going to
practice going to the gym three times
whatever the thing might be that you and
your therapist are working through go
three or four times before you bail
and if you've never been before expect
it to be uncomfortable
having surgery to get your knees fixed
is uncomfortable
getting shots when you're sick is
uncomfortable
healing is often uncomfortable and when
it comes to feelings and emotions
you just gotta power through
it's not gonna be comfortable and that's
the point
we do hard work and counseling so that
we can breathe at home
so that we can have peace in our souls
peace in our living rooms peace in our
bedrooms peace
it's hard to hard work
talking about somebody hurting you and
you're still married to him
talking about how you let your kids down
It's hard talking about how your parents
let you let you down and you still gotta
see them every Christmas or you think
you do it's hard it's hard how your body
failed you and you got sick
how you're you feel like your wife
failed you because you got cancer like
all those things
it's hard
expect it to be challenging okay expect
it to not quote unquote feel good all
the time
in the new modern era expect your
counselor to challenge you if your
counselor I've left counselors and
psychologists before because they
weren't challenging me
they just kept saying how does that make
you feel
my counselor now she challenges me
pushes buttons and I need that I love
that and that's a new wave of therapy
and I'm so grateful that it's it's made
its way into counseling rooms all across
the country you don't want an abusive
person telling you you can't believe
that and that's bullcrap
but you do need somebody pushing on you
and challenging you appropriately okay
so that's how to find a therapist how to
find a therapist listen if you need
somebody call
I don't care how tough you are I don't
care what your job is I don't care how
if you've been before and you got burned
call
you are worth being well
so is your family
I love you guys